okay so we'll be going live in three two
and one
welcome community meeting my name is I
will be chairing the meeting this
evening so how do people have done it to
start with we aren't expecting a mess
with a firearm so if one does go off you
can please follow us to the car park
over the road so we can check
on you go ahead and just want to make
sure everyone safely your mobile phones
if you could turn them off or at the
very least the silent please I
appreciate some people will need to use
them
um it's like Beyond silence and prevent
any instructions for that would be
terrific
the meeting is a meeting in public it is
not a public meeting so only those
people that have registered as people
will be committed to do so at the
appropriate time I'll call you forward
you can set up one of those three guests
in front of you here and I'll give you a
lot of time to use the microphones if
you press the button in the middle it'll
turn right and then just a little bit
away from my iPhone
okay some instructions then if I make so
to my far right we have Mason who is our
Community Services representative to my
immediate right we have an Amy Shipley
who is our solicitor and our planners in
no particular order are 0
30.
Paul Thompson who is joining us on uh
remotely experience now and to my
immediate left is David Jeffries who is
our planning managers
picture yes my role is to provide
impartial device
I should also have said that we are of
course being recorded within my stream
because it hasn't happened
if you check display on YouTube if you
want to watch this back when you're
inside
um okay let's get into the easy progress
so first of all apologies for absence
please
apologies chair from the council Iraq
and Council Adam is substituting and
Council apparently substituting for the
Vegas
okay if we don't have apologies from the
United States
okay understood thank you very much
about disclosure time as we have any
disclosures of Interest please
no
um I have one that's very minor um
I was contacted by Resident requesting a
site visit and they were passed on to
the war members Community Services I'm
very sure with that in mind so I thought
about
thank you chairman
this is a full-time application the
direction of born swelling the
application site is located outside the
daughter very boundary of Welcome
alignment and is denoted by the red line
number
nature as opposed to meet a local need
a proposed site plan the darling will be
cited for to draw in line with the dying
to the whites this is
proposed to the north of the dwelling
along with an axis drive with a passing
place and being an election point
the site will be served by an existing
access on the Barton Road
here we see the proposed elevations that
the coastline is a shy star Bungalow
with the external pricing materials
comprising a combination of Timber
weatherboarding and red brick with
natural slide root tones
this North elevation will be the
elevation facing the highway
on this slide we see the proposed score
plans of the valley the dwelling would
have two bedrooms
now we've gone to post class this image
is taken looking into the side facing
towards the South with the neighboring
trolling The Hive seeing here on the
ledge
the site sends a depth of 190 meters
here we are in the approximate location
of the proposed Valley facing in a
Northerly direction towards the highway
Boston Road the neighboring trailing
known as the Supreme is seen here on the
left hand side
this is just taking from the site access
off of the road facing the southerly
direction into the side with the high
again seen on the left
finally we have a street view image of
the access taken from the opposite side
of Boston Road facing in the southwest
Street Direction
personality meets the policy
requirements for local news values
except in that it does not have the
support of the correct Council our
search of proposal has some conflict of
development plan with the shortfall in
southern custom build housing is a
material consideration that is
considered to outweigh this in the
planning balance
example opposite recommendations you go
on subject to a legal agreement and the
conditions is detail in pain is 26 and
27 is an agenda and the updates and the
updation thank you sir thank you very
much let's call our first week of the
evening who is councilor Appleton
Enterprise Council
I believe you've been here before so you
probably know the drill already dude but
your past three minutes I'll give you 30
second warning before your time is up if
you say seeking questions afterwards
that'll be great otherwise whatever
you're already going to tell us about in
the middle and then control is yours
thank you very much
the applications for a single stories
it's like we we for the site um
and it's sort of behind the heads right
that's where that's okay
um the application is for myself
the next slide
it is outside the settlement boundaries
sandwiched between two residents
composite of high to the East and the
suburbation to Key West
the
map on the right is supposed to show the
filter area boundary which is donating
in a slightly heavier black line
yeah
there are four criteria applications
status first it was demonstrated
cutting off the 2019 has a leader
identified a new smaller drawings that
enabled 18 residents to downside to stay
in the bridge Beyond these days our
convention regencies and without
pedestrian infrastructure of this
proposal biology Department
secondly it must be small scale
returning intending the residents to
downsize proposal as a large booklet
foreign
finally
Paris Council does not support
application letters that support all
fail to consistent
so this is a prophecy for an individual
need rather than a future community
the tax officer said in America National
policy guidance away heavily in favor of
glasses missions such as
inappropriate of medications
there's nothing in supplication to
support emotions this adult is the
appropriate medication
inappropriate location
success
Richard
um you just mentioned uh Transformer but
I've been quite catching you mentioned
the report by I believe the district has
won the 23rd of March yeah a little
further
um
yes so uh this was the local capacity
that I'm responded to comments on
supplication in conclusion they say it
is considered the principle of the
government in this location but not to
be acceptable that's a proposal that
could not be adjacent to the identified
anyway
that it will not be the location
requirements of cs plus or cs15
history that proposed does not have a
supporting cs50
19.
any other questions
thank you very much for your time
contribution series
[Music]
foreign
ers
Mr Murphy you plan to speak for the full
three minutes oh yeah yes marvelous and
then I'm presuming uh four questions
that's right yes okay okay
developers otherwise I'm already in time
to actually Sherman in June 2022 this
planning application was taken to
committee and recommended for approval
the parish council did not turn up to
speak and so the decision was delegated
to officers for approval
rather bizarreling the parish council
has found a way for this application to
return to committee three months later
by complaining they were not consulted
on an amended plan to reposition the
building
the applicant is dumbfounded that the
parish council has a second chance to
speak to committee to having served the
first chance
dealing with the planning issues the
committee report is happening with the
design scale materials landscaping and
location of the proposed house
so what about its principle
this is a proposed Sudafed bundle that
fulfills two roles firstly is the
Southfield house and secondly is a local
needs house
as a self-built house it lies adjacent
to a local service Village and
contributes towards meeting the
identified children on self-build Lots
in the district
given this core strategy on a major plan
to do not have a policy on sale built
and its location complies with the
emerging staff the self-held benefit is
sufficient in itself to Grant planning
permission
as the local news house the foreign
evidence is relevant Mr and Mrs Gates
and their elderly mother will live in
The Bungalow and they have a strong
Parish connection dated about 30 years
only moving out of the parish in 2019.
the 2019 housing needs survey identifies
a need for five two-bedrooms and twelve
homes for households with a local
connection
this bunker meets both tests
labor plan policy hou four supports
fungus
There are 16 lessons of support from
local people and it has the support of
the rural housing officer for
Warwickshire rural community council
disappointingly it does not have the
support of the parish council
however in terms of objective evidence
this proposal clearly meets policy tests
to your local needs driving
instead the objection for the power of
council focuses on whether its locations
and so it is adjacent to the Village the
loss of all fisheries and the size of
the storage space in the group
the committee reports carefully explains
that as a matter of planning judgments
the proximity of the proposed by the
books to several other houses and
incoming a gap in the street scene may
consider Tracy to the bridge
the tree survey describes this as a very
poor quality auction and only dead and
dark water trees will be removed with
the new bridge trees and in this regard
there was no attraction from the council
psychologist pathetic act so in
conclusion understanding the parish
council objection the proposal is
falsely compliance as a self-built work
on these fundament and the chemistry
report recommendation for Grants is
correct thank you
thank you
that's just a great question now you
mentioned 16 letters of support
any other questions
no in that case both of you thank you
very much what you agency
okay we have no uh Ward hamburgers to
speak so we will move now to Fox Park
opening offices does anyone have any
questions I'd like to ask
no
let's move your survey if you would like
to pick this up that's apparent
thank you chair and I would like to
thank the officer for a very
comprehensive report on this
um
the evidence is clearly identified in
the report we have a housing needs
survey which identifies five the least
five two-bedroom condos this is a
considered two-bedroom Bungalow we also
have our note in the wealth of
neighborhood development plan policy hlu
4 which also states that the building of
bungalow should be encouraged and very
well aware of the self-build policy
coming through in this app
um I feel like a particular in chosen
snow there's no representation from the
old member who would normally if there
was a bit major concern from a community
perspective make some comment because I
know the Council of her together is
always very hot on the case if she has a
problem so this there was no
representation in the report and I I'd
like to propose that we go straight
forward Commission
you very much Council James
so to me it's on surf field you have an
obligation to provide several plots and
we're short on numbers
um
comes together aspects as far as I'm
concerned two-bedroom Bungalow unusual
needs to be built they are in demand I'm
very happy to second one
thank you very much anyone else like to
speak before votes
no in that case we have proposal to
Grant because of Harry is consented by
Professor Jennings who are planting
airline with the office recommendations
foreign
thank you Shannon
the application sites obligation is
located in the village Wales and is
marked by black circle on this map
this slide shows the application sites
outlined in red the site comprises of
the parts of the land located to the
east of the v4035 settled in the
Cotswold area about standing attributing
the site falls in the bill to carry
about money into the settlements as
identified by the whales and Winchester
neighborhood development plan although I
know affection to the rear of the site
towards outside one of those pair of
boundary
and as you can see here it follows the
Contour of the feels boundary again
science is a public house known as the
game sim the pastor land consists of
growing Tunes to building known to the
17th to early 18th century with later
editions a large garden to the Eastern
property and amical park into the rare
through a brick Archway which
the application seeks Planning
Commission has changed the use of the
public health to living accommodation
the ground floor comprises of the living
room Main Kitchen Bar kitchen Cellar
straw and an outside bar
first and second floor is the
residential we're supposed to intent to
the ground floor of the building to
become residential inside of creating
one single dwelling house in the site
The Proposal does not seek any external
alterations
here we have images taken from within
the application site
the following plan illustrates the
existing ground floor layout
and this slide shows the proposed
internal alterations including remover
formal wooden bar as well as the removal
of modern partitions and Ceramics for
customer bathrooms
this Photograph shows the printerization
of the size as set out in the office's
reports an independent liability
assessments conducted officers are
satisfied that it has been demonstrated
that the site is no longer viable or
appropriate for business purposes in
line with property cs-22 it has been
demonstrated that there is no realistic
Prospect of the facility continuing for
commercial and your operational reasons
on sites to land the policy cs-25
opposite of also satisfied with the
proposal comprising part of the se1 of
the NDP
it's therefore offices recommendation
for the application to be granted
subjects the following conditions and
dates
for agenda thank you
very much for our first speaker on this
item who's the counselor a rich
internation Council
so good evening and welcome
you've probably got an idea of what's
going to happen you'll have three
minutes 30 second warning when you're
ready you press the button in the middle
one will start my final
the gating has been a treasure path for
brailles history for over a hundred
years and within the neighborhood plan
is identified as the only local amenity
in Upper rails
a rushed decision here based on
questionable data within the context of
covid and even potentially cause claims
by the applicants
which constitutes clear neglect and
irresponsibly and irreversibly affect
both the current computer generations of
residents of rails it could be odd
people granting this application might
compound further wider precedence of the
unethical but highly lucrative potential
strategies to purchase discounted public
houses in preparation to convert them
into residential houses ready for
profitable onwards sale
all for heavily discounts and business
rates the gate table was potentially not
set up for Success from a start
initially closing the kitchen to
apparently made this a private kitchen
and toilet and then closing the Lounge
Bar to make this a bedroom or slash
living room halving the training area
in a plethora public objections indeed
10 to the brailles population a lack of
consistent food offering considerably
reduced people's ability to use the pub
Edward Cole your advisor stated the
trading areas are so small the property
is simply unable to accommodate the
numbers of patrons one would consider
requisite to be sufficiently sustainable
Mr Saunders contributed to this by by
closing the Lounge Bar he also started
selling antique chairs tables and
dressers that closed further areas of
the barn
when happened kobit 19 and people's
temporary reluctance to publicly
socialize it's easy to argue that the
data that has been used to assess the
economic liability is misrepresentative
of future viability
furthermore the applicants claim that he
has seen it passed through many tenants
none lasting more than a few years at
most is simply false
the previous owners of ownership for six
and a half years with success
and even offered to buy it from Hook
Norton Brewery
the confidential Financial appraisal
undertaken by Mr Saunders was not
audited nor professionally prepared It
is believed that you will not have
receipts for many of the purchases
mentioned
if there was not potential viability for
more creative landlords why would Henry
Jarvis another pug owner in the
surrounding area publicly claimed in his
objection to this application that I
quote I would happily out this to my
portfolio of 30 seconds lastly the Paris
believes to get in to be an asset of
community value and has done since 2018.
this application was rejected by
Stratford District Council on the
grounds of the Dayton is not
economically viable Based on errorless
data supplied solely by the applicants
planning consultants and without any
further communication to the browse
Parish Council I've rushed an ill
thought through a decision with simply
amounts of gross negligence and be
viewed with historical shame imagine
this has happened to the Royal Oak of
vodka which went from the derelict part
to holding a Midland star and the old
butcher shop in Long Compton now turned
into an oversubscribed nationally
recognized restaurant less than 20
covers okay so I'm afraid I'm going to
have to stop you there or ask me to make
one final closing time it is our ethical
duties probably Market the premise and
alternative and better ownership thank
you
[Applause]
French slightly by 15 seconds I am going
to have to give that to the applicant
agent in the beginning
members do we have any questions
you mentioned potentially the false
crimes
or something like that number everything
it seemed his pass through many tenants
none lasting for more than a few years
at the most
that is false you can go back through
the records and see that the previous
owners had it for six and a half years
for Success you can go through their
accounts on company's house they even
have a harder
um profitability Matrix because they
were having to pay rent that Mr Saunders
did not have to pay and it was still
profitable
yeah Castle Bells
yeah that's pretty good um
how long has it been closed I believe
since uh October 2021
I'll take it close to the year
yeah okay
any other questions
no that's my secret thank you very much
okay that's the one I speak of it is
certainly once again you'll have you'll
actually have three minutes in 15
seconds and I'll give you a 37 morning
when you're ready
thank you chairman um the applicant has
over 25 years experience at the club
ownership in the local area including
The George Hotel in rails and the Black
core skin ships them on sour which they
still haven't managed and is making a
profit
yeah because it hasn't over the date in
for 35 years and I stand by this s has
seen it pass through many hands none
lasting for more than a few years
the club was closed when African fought
it in September 2018. he then tried
every strategy to make him succeed based
on his long experience of management
course from September 2018 to March 2020
repairs and improvements were undertaken
at a cost of course two thousand pounds
the pub reopened in November 2018 for
six days a week measures taken then to
maximize the revenue included on my list
a listing in the camera could have been
guide making food on site a fish and
chip fan located outside Indian food
stores Taco stores Burger stands people
could bring their own picnics to the pub
a free barbecue musicians and
advertising on Facebook
yesterday remains only about 12 to 15
regular customers and the pub made
losses
after the first lockdown and a further
eight and a half thousand pounds spent
on improvements the pub reopened on the
4th of July 2020.
due to losses the openings declined from
five days a week to three days a week
and it made a loss of about 700 pounds
every week until it closed permanently
in October 2021.
the shop rise Energy prices means it
will never reopen
in October 2021 rails Parish Council
nominated the pub to be an asset of
community value however in December 21
Stratford or Maiden District Council
declined to register the povertising ACB
citing not enough evidence it is
economically available or a hope or
focal points for a significant
proportion of the local community
the Public Accounts have been
scrutinized by the council's independent
Financial Consultants
to concludes the gate in this not
economically available and that there
are 11 similar facilities in the Four
mile radius
the council's conservation officers
States the building was originally a
house and that the proposal was
Safeguard the future of the list of
building
there are four relevant policies cs22
and 25 of the core strategy and into an
se1 of the neighborhood plan
the proposal has to be rigorously
assessed by officers and it complies
with all these policies
in summary for many years the guardian
has rarely been used by villagers
the applicant is an experienced
co-operator and has invested heavily in
trying to make the pub successful
however The George Hotel is the main Pub
in brailles and Market forces near the
village can no longer sustain supus
therefore I asked you to follow the
officer recommendation and grasp out of
the mission okay
I've done it again within the 30 seconds
just as you're closing there we go thank
you very much do we have any questions
Matthew
that's James first
has the pump been marketed Market uh not
seated before since September 2018
meritas
I draw your attention to the policy cs25
it doesn't require any market system
policy components
yeah
okay
anyone else just cater Mouse
how far away is
natural I guess
I'm like
Mama tomorrow
that's okay
[Music]
thank you just briefly you say that the
landlord is um
trilarious measure to increase customers
the parody posing so much of the actual
area available for customers can you
explain how reducing or why those
decisions have been made I'm afraid I
can't because I'm not the club operator
so I I can't understand your question
now because I I've simply provided to
you the evidence about the evidence that
he has made to keep in public opinion
and universities put in if I can't
I can't give you an awesome question
about introducing the floor
um anyone else
yeah oh sorry about that um
um the Paris Council mentions the
previous
tenants report and there was some
question about the active study of the
information
in the publication I just wanted
yes I mean I I don't just speak to the
previous owner at Granite for six years
I've got no evidence of the country but
in my speech I said the applicant has
known he's a local person he's known the
site he's owned the pub for 35 years
so you go back in time for 35 years I'm
sure it has passed through many times
oh
um
different way is that would it be normal
practice for a successful oh
to close parts of the language parts of
um
whilst I appreciate the line of question
you're going on
um whether someone poses a room in their
Pub is not a planning consent for this
item
series
and that was one of the main reasons why
I will
talk it's yours I'm a little
uncomfortable with it
um perhaps we can talk more about
viability during the questions to our
office so we can find out exactly what
has been presented um
yeah does anyone else have any other
questions
contribution
[Music]
okay
um board member is here councilworthy
Hawkins good evening welcome good
evening
and you'll have five minutes I'll give
you 30 second warning whenever you're
comfortable ready to go just press the
button in the middle the floor is yours
this is a sense of incredulity that I am
here today until the applicant brought
the gate in had been a thriving club for
the local and damaged community of a
portrayals over the last couple of
centuries it has a long and proud
history of being at the house in the
upper brailles community fulfilling many
roles ranging from place of rest of
Willy Walkers the wedding reception
venue a place where only individuals
could go to find a friendly face to moan
and rejoice with the expensive beer
guard at the rear of the property was a
much sought after Haven with its
spectacular Outlook such as the Pub's
values of the community that the
defibrillator is positioned on the
outside of the building the
systematically the description of this
club as the going concern has been
breathtaking the removal of the
commercial kitchens to make way for a
domestic kitchen and toilet for the use
of only those living there the painting
the interior of the orb in order to
discover visitors the closure of the
book without warning and the erratic
nature of the opening hours with no
visible list of opening hours an area
previously used commercial purposes
within the pub and rapidly converted
Foods as a living room and a bedroom for
use on the owner doing this about the
appropriate commissions at the time
substantially reduced income
opportunities as one religious said to
me Mr Sam's involved that numerous
Tendencies with pubs within the
Stratford District area indicate he's a
very experienced landlord and knows
exactly how to run a successful form it
therefore stands to lease and that he
knows exactly how not to run upon two a
pub cannot be a successful or viable if
it does not open if it does not adhere
to advertise opening hours if it reduces
the amount of room available for
customers to actually Gathering the pub
and buy drinks and Paul does however
become a highly lucrative business
opportunity when it has given them
permission to convert to a residential
dwelling the game was sold for 290 000
pounds in 2019 if it goes on the market
as a dwelling it's valuable average of a
million pounds though with extensive
beer garden and car park which also
afford the opportunity for residential
developments with the appropriate
consent which could chuckle the million
of its residential value it is not the
pop business in this location that is
unsustainable the building is merely
owned by someone who no longer wishes to
ruin the building as a pub and the
comments submitting on the planning
portal and the volume of them you have a
clear indication that this kind of
feeling associated with this
difficult to me that the gift should be
given preferential and some might say
Speedy passes as a party system with a
recommendation to approve where not five
miles away the Chariton Isles reopened
with great success after several years
of closure and the pops and Hounds in
Great Wolf the start commission for
change of use to residential purposes
and again such permissions of not being
granted
the difference in valuations between a
pub and a residential dwelling is huge
and will have been a very careful
consideration if not the only
consideration in today's application the
11 facilities listed in the report
before you were always there if not more
and the problem is not successfully and
profitably before Mr Saunders bought the
premises it never has relied on Thailand
locals and was a destination of the
passing traffic and those living in a
wider locality the trading area also
mentions is so small because Mr Saunders
has purposely ensured that this is the
case why would anyone want to reduce
profitability unless the plan was to
always ensure that the pool began to
dwell in policy cs25 has not been
legitimately approved no audited
accounts have been provided and look at
the head of reduction of document
supplies in its application does not
prove legitimacy and make it impossible
to judge if change of use consent is
given today and each and every member of
this panel they just think very careful
about the consequences of their actions
as we will see a plethora of the pubs
closing in the districts in order to be
turned into the much more valuable
residential dwellings most of the way to
our best traditional development in Cal
parks and beer gardens and might even be
tempted to set up a pump bag Consulting
myself the most operandi will be to
offer three feet of fat or no food and
not to actually open its own to
potential customers as always seems to
me that this is all you need to do in
order to obtain a change of use it is
quite simply unheard of but I've talked
to Simply exchange for residential
purposes without the first going to the
open market the valuations for the open
market will be much less than the 290
000 pounds originally placed by Mr
Silvers because of the visible damaging
in terms of the training opportunities
in the pool these changes can however be
reversed and the looks like come expect
to have the heart of the community say
in Upper rails beating loudly and
proudly once again it's a pop of Sultan
owner who actually wanted to run a pub
rather than someone who really wants to
convert a pub to a much more valuable
residential dwelling
[Applause]
thank you very much remember if you have
no questions to cancel all the audience
please
as well
good evening
um
has has nobody come forward in a year
saying I want to find the power that's
as a going concern I've never been on
it's not on the open market that's the
whole issue but we've already got
anecdotal information I believe it's on
the board so that somebody has actually
offered to buy it and whenever it's a
very concern but unless it goes to the
open market that can't proceed so so
it's someone that has to come forward to
buy it on the official objectives
so just wait a minute please I'll ask
you to come back and when I'm ready but
please ask members of the public not to
shout out we're trying to operate the
meeting properly sorry cancer on the
call till like when people have been
putting clients it was 110 if not 113
comments back Central Services put in
the locality has actually written in his
statements but he's more than happy
would be happy to take on we can't buy
something if it's not for sale and
that's solution here it can't be taken
over if it's not for sale okay so
remember so we've got any other
questions
thank you very much for that
presentation
point though um you you said that there
was no visible list of opening hours
and that's that's been that's been
that's back to back toe position so what
are you having a brailles is um
I mean it's just I feel it's just it has
just been a way of showing how much are
on the book
okay any other questions
no that's all it is thank you very much
for your time contributions
um okay we'll move into points of
clarification or offices I'm getting
there might be a few including we might
skip this off councilor Jennings
have autism accounts being presented
um
and is there any requirement to put the
property on the open market
foreign
policy cs25 states that it is expected
that the existing Community facilities
such as shops codes medical and Leisure
will be retained unless it can be
demonstrated that one or more of the
following criteria for classified
so there is no realistic Prospect of the
facility continuing for commercial and
or operational decisions on that site
that's the first one and the second one
States the lands and the property have
been actively marketed or otherwise made
available for similar or alternative
type of facility that would be of
benefits community so I'm not aware that
the site has been marketed since
September 2018 real estate purchased and
however abiding to that policy would
just have to specify that one
foreign
[Music]
through the application
[Music]
um
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
my God
I know it's about one of my healthy
information here so it was from October
oh sorry this would be our first
Community I apologize
wall of 500 looking for that I'm going
to ask another question if I know okay
the um so we've heard that the kitchen
and the lounge will both change into
residential views from sort of a huge
binder what kind of stuff presumably an
upstairs flat yeah I'm going to assume
that they would otherwise have fallen
under the current use which would be
full apart
am I right for thinking that converting
the kitchen the lounge to residential
use only is it which is playing or is
that am I wrong
okay
yeah that would be correct so it would
be a breach of time so that's been done
and was it investigated by the
authorities
sorry to delay I understand that the
period of the financial information
provided was covered from September 2018
to March 2020.
10
thank you Council problem
was that covering a period of time as
well
to put that I've looked at recent
trading or did it go back further than
that
was crazy as a lot of information
collided by the app because it looked
more generally with the viability of
operating Club in this location as well
and it looked at
um what competition there was what the
trading background for public house as
well as the current time and it worked
on an assumption of a postcode return to
normal training
but with some consideration I think also
an increasing energy premises and
increasing attacks on
drinks which has been a background
in the
markets
okay thank you
it gives a broad
conclusion of operation of a pub with
specifics to this site at that correct
things yes
the training conditions about the
specific conditions for this
kind of presumably would have looked at
the pub as a whole environment and what
could be approaching into
photos
okay thank you that's okay
thank you chair after policy cs25
Healthy Communities
um it it identifies four four reasons
that we have to satisfy the Deep
benefits and it is expected that
existing Community facilities such as
shops Parts medical and Leisure will be
reclaimed unless it can be demonstrated
that one or more of the following
criteria satisfied on the basis that
only one of those four
because of the viability study has been
given what weight should we give to only
one of four criteria being
um
being being highlighted
um my regional policy is that the policy
requirements is for one or more of those
criteria to be satisfied and if one or
more is not met then policies man
Direction
that's a problem
was there any comments about the
decision to reduce the amount of trading
efforts
which is essentially affecting the
vulnerability
from from the consultant would that have
been usual practice
report there's no comments in that
respects in terms of you being able to
reduce the strategy
foreign
history prior to the current owner where
for more accounts it seems to have been
an extremely successful opportunity
if it's only looking at um
for that
so no I haven't consulted a group of
Japan been considering viability
insurance has had a large profits
depreciation property costs obligations
trading potential wages expenses and
losses
but not the previous
not under previously not the historical
idea when it was rather than both
successfully
that's right
that's my opinion for that slightly um
when was it purchased from but Norton
breweries
September 2018
report this was definitely done by an
independent body
yes kitchen five offices of the council
thank you very much
unless there are any more boxification
yeah
the the accounts before the actual
report was reduced in size they would
only figures but that could promise that
when it was reduced inside
many
times
I haven't had those their confidential
documents but I don't believe when it
was produced dated back to consideration
yeah because obviously
revenue
for producer
I don't see anything provided the
information to previous owners and and
their accounts
is
James
I think we'll probably be a bit careful
though if you want to see
um we're talking about the reduction of
size of the inside of the pub and all
the rest of it
um we don't know the background of that
really tells you a lot of something
quite unique evidence as it might I mean
it could be reduced because painting
costs will look it wasn't pliable to use
that actually there was some other
problems so I think how to sort of take
into account
um the evidence which we've been
presented
um
cs25 is a policy which we have and then
we have to meet one of the four criteria
and that's what the policy says and
obviously they have met one of the
criteria
um
the UK Hospitality sector anything is
predicting 10 000 clubs and restaurants
are going to go under well that's due to
Market forces the world's changed and we
could go back to pre-day 2018 you can
look at that it's the relevant data
world's changed times have changed
um
at the moment I I appreciated to be some
emotional one and I'm struggling to see
where we how we could go against the
officers recommendations
[Music]
thank you Chad
um I've got great sympathy with the
Villages of France because I'm they're
taking questions about this but as the
planning committee that we have to look
at what is in the front of us
but I am as much as I would love to use
this application I am struggling to find
a material planning reason that would
stand up
in with the planning on the spectrums
because at the end of the day we have
policy cs25 which is why I asked the
question because I was anxious to get
some clarity of that
um I find it extremely frustrating that
the top hasn't been put on the open
market normally when
um anyone has a business and it's not
going particularly well the first thing
you do is actually put it put it up on
the market have a work with you know I'm
sure who would be a Consortium with
villagers and brailles who will be very
keen to buy them up but it's not for
sale so that route
that energy is gone but I'm struggling
to check because I'm I'm sitting here
great sympathy unless somebody can find
me you know a
a material find a reason to use to
refuse this I'm going to have to propose
that we Grant
um
regressively yes it is because we have
to make a decision tonight we can't
prefer it we can't get more more advice
um but if if one of my colleagues has
got
um a strong amount of material primaries
and to go against that that I would be
welcome to hear it okay thank you very
much councilman it's interesting
could not be referred to
uh
I presume you're wanting more Pharisee
and understanding of the viability which
have a viability report that has been
provided to us and we have been given a
recommendation based on that report okay
if you wanted to if you can but only did
requires a request reason for for why
you have an issue with that report oh
yeah thank you just um I
I looked at some stats for tonight and
you know we've got 400 Parks closed in
2021 and 200 closed since first Harbor
she was down to 2022.
um
you'll see
[Music]
[Music]
um
understood these communicates
okay and keep cats around
thank you
um
aspect of the report with regards to me
find that it mentions any proposals that
would involve the laws
um should should have the viability
analysis carried out but it also fit and
it's important for the local community
and that they seem to be somewhat found
together in that paragraph and I think
that's clearly quite contingent to how
this is being assessed
I'm really concerned about how that
viability assessment's been carried out
given the
um
the time scale that it's looking at I
think it's fair to say that it will be
it today they have an Outlook it's it's
also not uh it shouldn't be taken as the
only
assessment that could be made on that
albeit that we've done an independent
assessment I think that there should be
enough of a gap within that paragraph in
particular so you'll be clear and
overwhelming ways of support for the
local community has for it should be
enough to override that
considering that there are no other main
factors under cs25 but it seems to be
considering so I
uh proposed that on that basis we um we
go against the opposite of
recommendation
problems
[Applause]
thank you very much um I will need to
understand this very clearly your plan
and reason to go against your
government's recommendation but we can
come back to you that's a chance
to uh popularity contest
we have to agree to developable material
planning matters
um
will be going along with Council of
Paris and uh sucking doing the motion
the ground
um
around viability right it does concern
me that
the evidence we've heard if you can
cancel away your policies Plus
seeming to indicate that there has been
quite
deliberate
attempts to reduce the viability
of this economy
um I mean and the independent liability
assessment
states that the trading area is so small
that the property is simply unable to
accommodate the numbers of patients one
considered requisitories and
sufficiently sustainable
but the decision to make the trading
area so small to make it unviable has
been made by the present management
so I don't really that that independent
viability essentially does being flaws
me and I am also concerned that none of
financial basis we have looked at the
previous
regime so I know we all know that code
is happening all sorts of things that
have happened but I would certainly be
much happier
if we were able to see
financial data Financial assessment that
looked at the profitability or viability
of it prior to being taken over in 2018.
you know it does seem but as soon as
this particular owner took it or manager
took you know
embarked on a planned
reduction in environment
that's the best thank you um before we
proceed I'm going to remind them to the
public once again that only people who
are registered people members of this
committee are permitted to speak please
can you refrain from shouting out or
coughing some words that is disturbing
the flow of their meeting
if it happens again we will be going
into private session
now while we're on that subject we can
if you wish move to the private session
anyway to discuss the probability report
you have to go into private succession
for that because it is confidential
pertains from the confidential
information I'm assuming that no one in
this community has read the Bible
Council parathasiogenics yes has anyone
else
would it be beneficial if we went into
private session
yeah I've seen lots of nothing you still
wouldn't be assessing 2018 at the moment
you don't know what that report contains
so you're basing your assessment of what
you think it might contain what you've
heard from public representations I
suggest we do read it you can of course
continue to hold your view once you've
read it if I suggest you do it before
meditation
so we want to do that now forgive me
because I do not have the appropriate
wording in order to take us into the
foreign
turn off
access to information Exempted
information paragraph three information
about financial or business Affairs of
any particular person including the
authority of that is holding that
information
therefore under their clothes you can go
into private
session
I guess okay in that case we are moving
into private section five please ask
everyone to make their way out into the
employee and we will bring you back
today
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
everyone
[Music]
please make sure your microphones are
off and remain off throughout this this
is quite a confidential and economics
microphones
reliable and possible to make sure it's
off
he actually
liability accessories
let's make one's answer's got the live
feed up there at the moment it's
pictured on all of us so we need to make
sure that he's got the adjourned or
private section whatever slide up and
that the red line was around
[Music]
[Music]
to the left
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
you know
that would be said
thanks the um
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
foreign
very nice
description
okay ladies and gentlemen thank you for
your patience um just so you know we
have now had an opportunity to have a
look at viability assessments and we
will contribute in the debate
about the
the tying of the importance of the local
community to the other aspects that
we're looking at in the cs25 what
is there any tangible link within that
cause of the
the
um all strategy the the means that the
community
Imports the local community is more
material than it were than it may be for
any other sort of applications the only
reason you know I don't understand it's
not a
huge contest sort of thing but this but
if it's in the if it's in the writing
that it's a you know important to the
local community it's not like it's just
some some people are happy with the
house coming up it's tangible and in the
paragraph So what weight can we afford
that
thank you
I think that you've probably heard the
Clauses in cs25 the making clearing what
the criteria are when
um a Community Asset
um
would potentially not being saved
so it has to be one of those four
criteria
um obviously the aim and the objective
of cs25 overall is to ensure that
Community facilities are
again and will be improved throughout
the district
but in some circumstances it is from the
next sector except that they they will
be um it will change to some of the use
is and these are the criteria which the
council has adopted
Council James
yeah a lot of YouTube contests yes but
we have to go again we have to go with
everybody's
um It's Made well in everyone's eyes be
a an asset of community value but
um that was projected in December 21 and
therefore we have to go ahead of us
thank you
um yeah hello uh I'm forced to agree
with cancer Jennings and Council
apparently uh we've taken time Concepts
and have a good book through
a good read of the uh reliability is
testimony I'm satisfied and convinced by
that that it is a solid assessment of
reliability of this business
it just isn't reliable as a business
um as Council James was saying it's not
a pop back contest the one thing I
really want to do is to say yes I'm
going to back the members of the public
here I want to say that but at the same
time I will be irresponsible if I did
because there will be an appeal against
us if we went today if we went against
office recommend relationship and it's
my belief that we would lose that appeal
incredibly sick
all residents will be liable to the cost
of that and that's just not responsible
okay
so I want to be popular I want to do the
thing that everybody wants to work out
because so I'll be supporting the
recommendation
Emma thanks very much unless anyone else
wants to speak I will close off and then
we'll move to a vote we have a proposal
to Grant the amount of accommodation and
that has been separated anyone else will
so to speak
for me I think cancer can I sitting
there on ahead we've had a thorough
review of the viability assessment
um and it has become clear certainly to
me that is a broad review
not just of the councilor presented by
the African but a broad review of The
Pub its Fidelity and surrounding areas
ability to expand and improve itself it
is clear from that
it's deemed at the time's not viable
the African has therefore met one of the
four criteria that needs to be met as
part of policy cf25 and therefore what
might have no plan easy to go against it
as much as I would love to see that Pub
do well
have to consider the application that's
put in french lesson we have to consider
the evidence that is being presented in
that evidence in over one I will also be
voting among jobs
we have a proposal let's move to a
proposal is to Grant in unjust
recommendations
[Music]
absolutely
status
okay okay members members going to get
your attention back to the table please
um we just have a couple of minutes
there while I'm into the public left the
room
um we are now going to go to our next
application
2102 491 Field view from Temple Run of
proteins
thank you
thank you chairman good evening this
proposal seeking planning question for
the eruption of seven Gypsy travel spots
the site is allocated to the north of
the village of Temple Grafton uh in an
area of open Countryside as denoted by
the black dots on this plan besides is
also within a designated special
landscape area
uh here we see the composed red wine
boundary for the application one can see
here plots uh denoted one to five uh
which are already in situ lawfully with
the benefit of planning permission this
proposal probably the same thing is even
to create seven additional pictures at
the same site shown here plots six to
twelve
here we see the post like layout plan
that's submitted uh one conceive of
course development which shows each
individual plot would benefit from a
parking and turning area a day room and
the static caravan the vehicle access
will be achieved off the existing
analysis
thank you
um vehicle access would be achieved off
the existing access with my cursor here
and here we see submitted plans of the
proposed day room
uh we have some photos
on uh Croft Lane looking Eastward at the
existing point of vehicle access to be
used as part of this proposal it's
uh yeah we announced it was just inside
besides again looking eastwards I wanted
to see the existing pictures to the
right here
um here we're now sitting in a similar
position this time looking to the left
where six of the proposed seven pictures
are proposed to be stationed here
um
in a linear fashion to linear to the
access track
um here in our super dinner site come
back westwards towards the highway
with the existing pictures this time on
the left
uh finally here we'll sit on the edge of
the side looking across where six of the
seven post pitches would be pose to go
uh looking again in the production of
the highway
um The Proposal of seeking an extension
to an intensification of an existing
Gypsy travel site not the creation of a
new one there is a clear identifier or
need for additional pitches within the
district
um District being unable to demonstrate
widely housing Supply the districts had
the duty to provide pictures to meet a
significant short for identified by
empirical studies I refer you all to the
update sheets for further details share
the recommendations to grow next
application for reasons to sell Pages 59
and 60 original accounts thank you
thank you very much just for our first
people decided who has councilor David
keys
do you have anything cancer thank you
very much
you probably have a dry day now you'll
have three minutes have a good Thursday
and wonderful your time is up if you
stay seated the questions that'd be
great otherwise while you're ready
that's about the middle well almost
yours
chairman ladies and gentlemen welcome to
received notice that this application
was to go to committee we had a mere
eight days to prepare
we are straight away for a deferral but
this was refused uh we're still seeking
Clarity over some matters specifically
we would like to know the likely impact
of gypsy and capital policy being
transferred to Borussia County and how
that will affect the GTAA locally
there are parts of the officer's report
which we would Challenge and that we
believe will be best served by a Sonic
visit for these reasons we are now
referring uh requesting a deferral our
difficulties on this application or it's
disproportionate size and the
speculative nature of the development
proposal demographers are small
settlement and more than doubling the
size of the character site by an
additional seven households it creates a
nine percent increase in size of the
village
of course if there were houses they
would not be given permission as they do
not meet the criteria in the course
strategy
unlike the existing site this
application does not specify individuals
nor even families and their local need
is identified we must therefore look at
it as a speculative development of puns
on the open market over which there
might be no control of ownership
because there are no name documents we
believe this is not an extension to the
existing site but a separate application
once the current occupants of field use
that site that fortune must be returned
to Farmland but with no named occupant
condition on the application site it
could easily turn into a Transit site
with a high term range of residence
this would do not enough about the
community cohesion the officer is hoping
to see
not only that but the significant visual
harm done to the low County sitting as
it does in the oven special landscape
area and acknowledged by planning
inspectors would never have to be
mitigated
local public footpaths have now been
used more as a consequence of lockdown
disappointingly the Landscaping division
in those years ago by the inspector have
never been carried out and the existing
site remains highly visible from certain
Advantage points we're happy to
acknowledge the existing site is clean
tidy and well maintained we are however
unconvinced that this can be maintained
when not in the ownership of the
applicants or if this becomes a Transit
site
members of the committee will be aware
that permission has recently been
granted at appeal for one duty pitch on
a large field at the other end of the
village the applicants of which are
currently occupying unlawfully a
different part of the site it cannot be
right that one Community should shorten
a disproportionate responsibility to
satisfy the need for Gypsy and traveler
[ __ ] in the district due to the
federal and District Council over many
years to provide land for Gypsy sites
where you respectfully request that the
committee agrees to a deferral of this
matter in order that we can gain a
better understanding of the new
direction of gypsy planning in the
county and in order to facilitate the
site visit by the committee
thank you
it's just about to give yourself a
second woman so filing well within your
time thank you very much no too many
questions
Nick
that's the keys thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
unfortunately patients earlier on
okay we'll hold on next week on this
item who is our agent today Mr Michelle
Young
and welcome and again thank you for your
patience too
so the same age before you'll have to do
the next episode in the morning when
you're ready I'll start the timer before
this is always a tricky application to
speak about for Tipsy and traveling
sites are always contentious
this application has been and instructor
District Council for in excess of a year
now it was the first acknowledged in
August
last year and this has been largely down
to we've been told staff changes within
the system and maternity leave
at the end of 2020 a former employee
approach
and ask them to submit to the council a
call to sites
and are encouraged to apply for at least
five but more likely seven by Mr Griffis
as the council has a more than
significant shortfall at that time
golfer sites have been submitted back in
February of 2021 but yet as yet we have
not had any communication from this
Smith family have been on this site
since 2010. why you Smith the head of
the family still resides on site and
owns the land
their children have been sent to the
local school the grandchildren have been
sent to the local school
this application has been concept just
because of course any questions
minded forgive me for this exercise I
could see your your machine was flashing
blue and I think all of our sounds just
fine
so we may not have picked up any of what
you said on our recording so I apologize
don't make me do it again
you're so good
and I do apologize um it's frankly
embarrassing but our technology is scale
we'd like to do it it is working now if
anything it's actually a bit louder
um but if you wouldn't mind starting
again that'd be great I've reset the
clock so whenever you're ready you can
if you turn the microphone on
um
we appreciate that Gypsy and traveler
applications are quite often contentious
this application has been with the
council for in excess every year due to
your staff changes and your maternity
leave having been initially arrived in
August of last year
this family were approached at the end
of 2020 by Ian Griffith
office Council and he now no longer
works for the council and he requested
that they submit a call to sites they
were encouraged to apply for at least
five but more likely seven o'clocks
he said that this was due to the
canceled having a significant short form
hope the sites have been submitted it
was in 4th of February 2021 as yet we
have received no communication
the Smith family have resided on site
since 2010. Riley Smith the site owner
still lives there they've sent their
children to the Local Schools their
grandchildren to the Local Schools this
application simply came about because of
Paul persuades and should you be minded
to follow your office's recommendations
then we can provide the names of those
now grown children Ryan Smith children
and we can continue the personal
permission on this site with those
grandchildren
it will absolutely remain within the
family that reside in pitches 1 to 12.
this site is not at risk as flooding
highways have not rejected and there is
no data
to suggest that this is a dangerous site
in terms of traffic usage
there was a landscape appraisal
submitted for consideration and your
officers have acknowledged the contents
they're in
ask your office to step this is an
extension site not a brand new site
these plots are from persons who reside
on the site currently the dependence
people who have thrown in this area who
support the local businesses and who
want to bring their children up in this
area in the same way that they
themselves have been growing in the last
decade
I respectfully request you follow your
office's recommendation this is an
extension application and it could be
named permission if you so wished
as per the report it is in accordance
with your core strategy and the
applicant has accepted the suggested
conditions
this Council does have a significant
shortfall as identified by the GTAA and
your officer has said it would be
acceptable
I respect you request you follow your
officer's recommendation and Grant this
application thank you
thank you very much for holding your
time to apologies for the interruption
as well members do we have any questions
um if I may ask you you said you're
happy for uh the condition the
Restriction of who you live on the site
to be carried forward so if we were to
add that you'll be perfect
absolutely and as we've been asked the
names we could have provided them
together
that's it thank you very much indeed I
don't think there are any other
questions so thank you very much
contribution
more often
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's seven additional pitches seem to
be quite a large number all needed at
once and again more information is
needed
regarding cs21 the report notes that
there is a conflict as a site is an open
Countryside they're not close to any
facilities as described I see that to
mitigate this the facility is suggested
for cycle storage
I noticed this with a right Smile as the
officer suggests that the residents
could cycle from the sites are also good
within 15 minutes even when I was
considerably fitter I was without a
significant increase in traffic form
around 49 or 846 both busy roads it took
me longer than that going down there was
easy coming back there's a lot more
difficult
the report implies that sites like this
should not be assessed quote with quite
the same eye as other forms of
development I question why an
application for 2200 pieces of the road
could well be refused permission for
exactly the same reason I'm sure we all
know the reason that I could apply the
housing Service Supply
has noted the current occupiers are
considered untidy if this has maybe just
defined it then be a new site as long
family members then they have no idea of
this occupation
it's only fair to the residence
they are made aware of this in advance
approaching commission as an example in
ch-21i 2011 it states the cycle and
automatically unacceptable adverse
impact on neighboring residential
immunity including emotional chemical
activities
does that mean commercial activities can
take place again as this is an open
Countryside and in an SLA a condition
would appear to be reasonable under
those circumstances
but I asked the committee for a deferral
to assess the concerned ways this
evening namely is this in reality an
extensional to the size or effectively a
new one is an extension why on the
family members of identify where is the
proposal for the announcement of the
greatly increased size which is a
requirement the scientists within an SLA
in under prominent position previously
conditioned Landscaping has not been
completed and therefore the PC has
little faith that the condition proposed
will be implemented
the real trees were the trouble
arrangements as proposed would appear to
be in order as I seems something
practical the report says the site
should not have been an acceptable
adverse impact on neighboring
residential immunity houses to be
achieved conditions will have commercial
activities introducing the opposite
quotes as10 in the report that all other
types of development or activities in
the countryside unless you're advice for
setting policy in the course strategy or
making fully Justified offer significant
benefits to the local area and not be
contracted overall development strategy
of the district this is used as
justification for post-itiform to apply
therefore this application must be fully
Justified and what are the significant
benefits to the local area
this is a heart of the Parish of
concerns and his 10 goes on systemic
proposal should minimize the impact on
the character of a local landscape with
communities and environmental creatures
I feel the site visit would be
beneficial here
the courage is not being unusable
excited it is only fair that they're
genuine concerns or listening to an
address are therefore ask the committee
to defer this application for a site
visit and until all of your book
concerns can be addressed if members do
not wish to defer then please don't ask
for refusal thank you members
thank you
um
disciple where where is the closest
school to this side the primary school
in demographic the nearest other school
create an awesome
um as the crow flies three or four miles
46.
anyone else
that's probably
um we've heard from the agent sorry the
applicant I've been already translation
patients uh that was willing to accept
the personal time
does that begin if you're concerned it
certainly seems like he's one of them
yes a couple
productive obviously one of the main
concerns there's super scientists but
there are several number of other ones I
was going to speak to the landscape the
issues that they've already noted
take care of myself
okay and is there any other questions so
spend the first week of time
contributions
okay
let's try to get into our officers who
would like to answer your questions for
opposites against constantly
it's been mentioned about the previously
conditional landscape report being done
shouldn't be mindful to around this can
we have that implemented prior to any
work being done
okay
um I would be if there is indeed um
Landscaping that has not been fully
implemented that's regretable I think
the application before you receiving
cannot seek to retrospectively address
that amount of approved application to
be my personality
um could be there for implementation you
can manuscript in a very strict
landscoping condition on this which
could be will be done before about your
work clothes
yes thank you councilor for
clarification that there is a condition
to report put forward by the officer in
your particular perhaps condition before
is the suggested Landscaping details uh
with a stipulation of prior to
occupation
um but it's important in part by the
supporting landscape Regional impact
assessment that we're provided as part
of this application
thank you
yes thank you very much um
um I think the the previous issue is
about who the Landscaping the completed
before construction if I was correct
whereas this is part of occupation could
this be altered to the landscape that is
completed in advance of other work being
doubled because it might concern with
people that once the um
people will move it
I I can understand the sense of what
you're saying ordinarily what I'm trying
to do is ensure that the development and
the Landscaping occurred concurrently
and I think that that's probably a term
a phrase that we might Educators use
having Landscaping put in prior to
actually bringing operations
destroyed his new process
[Music]
and we've heard about the personal side
being carried forward are you
comfortable looking for that condition
on without the names at this point and
get those names later or we just put the
channels forward like this family I was
like a very cute Chef for raising that
issue that is new information that's
been brought to this committee which um
as you know in your agenda hasn't been
fully considered
[Music]
our recommendation is based on the
information upon idea which was that
these would be open market accounts
um and would not be constrained by such
a condition and that's our view if
members felt that it was harm rising
from
um you know proposed it would only be
um
mitigated by such a position they might
be reasonable and in accordance with the
tests sort of to post such conditions
that could be a breed in due course the
problem resolution
with the applicants and with the further
discussion about the names in the
condition that would be necessary
against with your agreement
foreign
um
one of the reasons you might choose to
impose a condition is that you want to
Across the Greater Community in cohesion
and proper management design and
conditioned relating to the Future
offices of my known persons like the
government needs in that respect do you
read my mind that David that was just
what I was going to say but you said it
more than quickly yeah I've just got
back to my point that was
and the pictures were originally going
to be open commanded as one of those
price
because they're going to be demanded
potentially will this affect our overall
number for the housing and man Supply
and understanding of State Council wants
to get across tonight brilliable thank
you
when it comes to cancer
thank you chair I just would like to
encourage the clarification on if the
site is named under the family what then
happens with the passing of certain
members of the family is there a
fallback
close because
the price is respect if we've got 12
pitches
all the same family
um and we've got grandparents
Etc what then happens to the pictures
when sadly perhaps
there isn't a member of family around
I'd just like some clarification on what
that then happens to pictures
and
the Traditions ordinary include a named
person and their dependents and widows
thereof and if members will find it so
consider the site except remember that
sort of condition it might also be
appropriate then
once it's no longer necessary for
occupation by those people being
response to its original condition
the difficulty that is that obviously
the Caravans of the use of the land but
there is associated development with the
Caravans as part of this application
Department
um
how you know buildings Associates
there is an issue there
or commercial activities on the site
thank you
okay has anyone else want to have
anything clarified before moving too
late
yourself
[Music]
constraints
I'm not going to move forward with this
and go with some recommendation with a
number of the conditions
um one being named family condition and
then start going down the family
um no business activities or commercial
activities and uh
um
foreign
[Music]
that you're wanting the Landscaping to
be done before occupation report before
work starts or concurring things
thank you
very much
okay I'm gonna look for a second sorry
guys
again
no everyone else happy there's no one
else wants anything okay let's move to
the vote then so we are the closest
Grant in unwell's recommendations of the
edition of the three conditions that we
have just talked about at least have a
share the plans first in favor
beautiful
[Music]
thank you
Road uh the application site is within
the adopted filtering Andrea Vista Navin
within areas of local Countryside to the
north and to the West
um here that we see the proposed site
layout plan illustrating three weddings
uh this plan here shows the proposed
vehicle access
um taken from the existing Asus truck
that is partly to be widened here
denoted by the area of purple for the
Belmont the access
here we have some indicative visuals of
the proposed development
here we see the proposed innovational
detail for plots one and two
and again here we see the elevations for
blocked three uh again we have some
photos surroundings
um here I've stood on the existing
emphasis track with me southwards back
towards the highway and one can see the
back of neighboring properties here to
the left off Harvard close
um here we have stood in the crew center
of the application site looking
Southward uh one can see the two barn
structures here that are supposed to be
demolished as part of this proposal
uh here once again we see the phone uh
one of the barns in Greater detail uh
also looking North westwards we can see
some good views here to the north and to
the west of the site showing um
agricultural land uh further afield
here we are stood
um outside the application site looking
eastwards across the Barns and also to
residential buildings ordering the site
uh to the north and to the east
finally here we are stood at the vehicle
points of access looking along the b439
both away from the village here to the
left and in this direction towards the
Village Center here on the right
um
having refused a scheme in this location
that was very similar to this one 12
months ago in his office's opinion of
previous concerns pretty amounts of
Highways have since been addressed and
approved is supposed to deliver three
family homes at sustainable location
within the adopted boundary of bidford
and even I have 30 Waters of the update
sheets for details chairman the
recommendations to grant for the recent
setup of pages 69 70 of agendas thank
you sure thank you very much indeed
that's all I first keep on entire who is
Mr solicitous who is the parish Castle
Club
hello hello good evening welcome and
thank you for your sessions
um after you know drill you'll have
three minutes 30 seconds
uh you will do so you have 30 seconds
press the button in the middle it will
turn red and whenever you're ready as
soon as you also start the channel
this application was considered by the
parish council in June 2012 having
already affected from an earlier
application in April 21 which was also
refused by strategic District Council
the parish council does not consider the
new application addressing the concerns
it raised in April 21 and result of
continuous objections on the ground that
it is contrary to the NDP policy env6
projection of the best and most
versatile agricultural land of
particular importance in the present
time when climate change and
environmental sustainability are at the
Forefront
dangerous access to an egressing from
the site to the view is impaired by the
bus stop and land Coast making it
difficult to see any incoming traffic on
the busy b439
it was interesting to note that the
planning office Estates in her report
under Highway matters and parking that
overall while parking on site is
considered adequate the access is not
considered to be safe having regards to
the number of planning to post the width
of the axis and The Pedestrian
visibility available
this would indicate that the officer
agrees with the Spanish Council but the
access is unfair and it is therefore
somewhat battling that the final
recommendation is to Grant permission
despite an unsafe access on an
increasingly busy road thank you
thank you very much we have any
questions
[Music]
I just wondered whether you could just
expand on the policy of the
n36 in your neighborhood Development
Department did you actually identify
this particular site as a as a an area
or even not predictively but we are
surrounded by pipes on agricultural land
and upon that so this site was not
basically I know not tested pancakes
any other questions
yes
a question that I'll be amazing about is
the visibility and the access of the
um where the guided by Otherwise
authority of this
um I'm concerned how how it should be
able to go against this one more
thinking
um but like now I'd like to put this
politely always go up to see they just
look at this on the map
foreign
[Music]
to this
straight away from the get-go because
there are no fundamental changes to what
happened last year when this was refused
and the highways put forward a case
to refuse it
um
they're not no fundamental differences
to what happened in my studio the the
line drawing actually isn't particularly
accurate because the lane that comes
down from the houses isn't straight it's
got a double leg halfway down
so although
it claim that it's 3.8 meters wide if
you take a long vehicle and go cordial
across that particular curve in the road
it Narrows down to 3.1 meters
so
the fire you know fire service today
require 5.1 so despite the cut being
increased the exit at the bottom is
still the same it's still like a bottle
with a narrow neck
by one and a half to three meters before
the driver can see left or right it
comes over the footpath and onto the to
the drivers before the driver can see
left or right
they're taking down a piece of the blue
wires wall which has been there for
several hundred years just to try and
improve it it really doesn't make a
difference to the bit of Australia on
the left or your exit in the site
to run to the right there are
the vehicles that have to exit again
the visible display the visual display
is hampered by the bus shelters now this
was shelter you'll see on one of the
pictures I think they've shared it on
one of those things
yeah that was shelter
five school buses stop there in the
mornings
it is crowded for a good three-quarters
of an hour same in the afternoon when
they come back off the bus from the
schooling officer this is a really busy
bus stop because it's the only one at
that end of the village
so it's always populated and
causes of fairness you can't see the
bottom of marriage Hill from there where
the speed limit drops from 50 to 30.
so that's a big issue
um
the state's really unsuitable because if
you think going back if you put the
picture back up maybe it shows up delay
no no that's it now
and
when I say that there's a curve in them
that you can't see around particularly
well
um that's from the top down but
the uh the big the big issue there is
you've got to get furniture trucks in
you've got to get Builders wagons in
there
and all they tend to do is to put some
gravel on top of this there's no it's
not going to be a matter of growth at
all it's just going to be uh
service
Refuge
it's going to be 12 winning events on
good week's day down there there's no
way to put them at the end of the road
they're gonna have to stand on the pain
they've got they've got business
sections within the where they're going
to build their houses but there's
nowhere to put the business until you
get to the bottom of the road they'll be
on the pavement further blocking views
from how when you're driving out of
there with a vehicle
the houses don't comply that NDP and
they're not sure there's a quite uh how
does it needs survey now
in the inner Court strategy the
development requirement sap
recognition recycling storage this is a
December 2018 name
residents are not to be more than 30
meters or 25 meters away from where they
leave the beach from the point of the
house to where they're legal this is 70
meters
so that's a big issue you've got to drag
them down 70 meters then they stand on
the pavement and block the page
so from that perspective I think I've
said all I need to say
that's a funny thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
[Music]
um
yes and the thing is just beyond that
bushels that would be talking about is
pedestrian Crossing into a development
of uh 79 or 80 houses so again warning
traffic time
as long as we might bring the kids go up
to take them to school in the mornings
so it's a well-wanted foot classes
again
in the photos if you could go back to
the
I'm just a couple of the show it looks
like it's got that we've already got
vehicles in there is this used
um on a regular basis a glamorous has
been used that
at the back of the field
okay okay
and is there any other questions
thank you very much for your time
patience and contributions
let's move to much complications of our
offices now I'm sorry but I'm going to
kick us off because
I'm
talking
um on page 67 of the report uh
Hydraulics matters and parking the final
paragraph of that states overall while
parking website was considered adequate
the access is not considered to be safe
and reverse number of days will pay for
all about them how are writing thinking
that is either a typo or is it
um it's not currently considered to be
safe but with the addition of the
condition and highways to achieve those
visibility space it can be achieved in
therefore that's why we've got a
recommendation approach
um it's unfortunate
um and it should have affected by myself
in your update sheets this evening so
apologies to agree for that
um I agree that to be a typo and that
officer finds the Development Authority
including highways methods to be
acceptable subject to the condition is
proposed and that is reflected by the
fact that the foreign
[Music]
sorry
thank you Jim I will endeavor if I just
don't share my screen if other people
want to ask other questions
thank you thank you Jeff okay well I can
pull up some satellite injury but
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here is the point of access in the
question
existing access
adjacent
Harvard close there you can see the
balance in question here
um
and this is the application site
thank you very much okay three four
we've already just five now I mean I'll
take you in order so cancel it first
thank you
um
cancer Fleming been used
a note on the report that there was no
response from there
favorite
and it's not unusual for us not to have
a wife
then positive County Council and
without a comment from there's no reason
for us to consider the application it's
not acceptable
from any of the residual issues
as a test
um thank you I'm still starting puzzled
but so I'm still asleep possible by this
final paragraph on the highway as much
as important
um
you said that it's a typo but what is
the type of I
should it say the access is considered
to be sunny or not at the end of the
first sentence yeah overall our parking
lot is considered accurately access is
not the knots shouldn't be there
lyrics
that's a strange construction and while
parking on the side is considered
adequate
the access is considered to be safe that
doesn't make sense dramatically I'm
sorry but that doesn't make sense I'm
concerned about that
I think I can advise that the comments
of the officer will need to be
consistent with the views of the highway
Authority
there is
acceptable subject conditions
it's it's
just a consideration about the business
Theory
um has been about Street seeing one to
see the clarification on the location of
vehicles
um
we've had some accelerated one of my
Awards a while ago
um
and I'm just concerned about this you
know
and making sure the bins are put in a
safe location when it comes to highway
safety business displays which is if I
put in the wrong location it could
potentially cause an Irish issue
police councilor it is quite difficult
to make accounts but there are things
shown
um being available
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
it's a small front door within the
daylight boundary parts of the ownership
of it
yes thank you very much
um uh Council of Jennings next please
let's do the with the loss of prime
agricultural land I just want to get
clarification of the footprint of the
proposed houses will cover the footprint
of the farmers this is going to be a
loss of difficult to learn
is that correct
thank you cousin it's so clear you're
asking is it it's going to be is there
going to be a loss of agricultural land
or were you asking about it
I'll try to find out whether it's going
to be lots of agricultural land or
whether these campuses basically cover
the footprint of the existing bonds
they couldn't see that there will be a
lot of popular and there was a change of
use of this learned as part of this
application to be converted into
residential use where members reside my
particularly to this language artificial
implemented it's not no longer being
agriculture use it would be for
residential uh use
um with regards to the footprint
crudely there are like three bars in
total there is one approximately on pots
one or two here I believe I don't have
exact floor Association is compared to
the existing agricultural buildings and
their homes and residential conversions
But to answer your main question that
quadril under the seat is
[Music]
is suitable to return to active
agricultural use
particularly what sort of things is now
identified
how wide is it
I'm going to put two cars apart safely
and I'm a width of six meters for the
first 13 meters
outside business
of the excess points for the first 13
meters away
um from their narrative single car width
of sorry a single width of 3.8 meters at
this point
the length of the track that is only
um 3.8 meters and how wide is a fire
engine
thank you
thank you councilor um I don't have that
information to hand here within the
containing the report
um officer has I I wouldn't wish to
venture a guess either officer has put
this has had scale plans and it's a
system on that basis and esteemed that
into practice surrender to be acceptable
um guided in part by the county highways
response of no objection offered in
respect to your second question of how
wide is a fire engine
um again I would I would not wish to
measure a guest to that I know I don't
have that information
[Music]
um
yeah I know you are uh
County do you know what's the top of
your head what it is and
[Music]
the advocate of what I'm calling Google
now this is clearly this is not clear
evidence this is just a Google the
average size is about 2.3 meters
I think I think we've resolve that does
anyone answer any questions they want to
ask of our offices before we lose five
debates okay let's get into our debate
if you're just going to kick yourself
thank you Chad I've actually got
something
on the report
um and I believe in view of the conflict
of
Highway's responses from its previous
one that was refused and this one I
would like the post defermented the site
and the site visit the highways officer
presence
that's right I'm very much hope I think
I've got similar concerns as well as the
I think about playing the bins and how
far they haven't come off which made me
generally unsatisfied telling the
government with presence of a County
officer and if we could get it
um fire and saw their input instead of
no no response that would be nice as
well
ask cancer
um okay
um before we take that vote we do
obviously still have an opportunity to
continue debating does anyone want to
continue debating and put any other
proposals forward Council Curtis has a
stand up to our foreign
[Music]
that restricts the width of the drive
the display line I think is very
important that could be very dangerous
okay thank you very much sorry
um
enjoyed it but I also think there was
reference to gravel on the drawing that
people have got to pull things across
gravel and they're very heavy because
their household waste bin is now not
texted until for three weeks it is very
difficult to pull a a full thing that's
Bloody Lane down the ground and dryer
because the wheels don't return so
that's something else I think we need to
look at the surface of the book when we
go for site for sale
okay that's quite a lot so I'm just
going to list these so that uh I know
we've got everything right so we at the
moment proposal is to defer so that we
can conduct a site visit and the point
of the conduction inside was it is to um
to consider this the visibility space of
the access to the driveway the length of
the driveway in terms of refuse and also
the ground the surface of the driver in
terms of refuse the width of the
driveway further apart in terms of cars
passing a bit in particular
um
Pharmacy audiences
et cetera Emergency Services access to
have I covered everything or is it was
there something else this one said
something else
there are a couple of surveys on the
national environment that had to be
repeated
okay so to get those completed and then
of course to make sure the report is is
absolutely patient that's again
officers okay
[Music]
a favor
unanimous so it is therefore results to
defer application
2201-071 and development frequency yes
[Music]
okay members
um he will hopefully have read that
those sheet and you will know that this
item is our last item this evening just
to make sure that everyone is clear and
understanding uh you'll see that
application 22 01054 fuel is the payment
in Balance road which ones out and the
Town Council have withdrawn their
objection and therefore two delegate to
officers without using
so we'll have another discussion about
it
so we are into our final item in the
evening which is that page of reference
2201 515 fql see the Bungalow employment
and I've sent an officer it is all
confidence Thompson who is online for us
at all of them
um
yes thank you Joe can you hear me
well you're quite quiet but um
but
whatever you're ready and come to
associate
thank you
uh right we are in uh Birmington this
evening
um we have
uh
and it's the building opposite the
application site is see the Bungalow
outlined in red
um also red is the list of building and
the green I believe is the public
right-of-way but I'm not entirely sure
it doesn't affect the application in any
case
uh we have
um
on the top here is is the proposed
proposal
um on the bottom is the is what's there
now uh you'll know also on this plan
um the blue land is also owned by the
applicant
right so this is what's there at the
moment
um
this Bungalow was granted Planning
Commission in the 1960s uh as an
agricultural workers dwelling with a
condition to that effect
uh about 2020 we received an application
to
um confirm that the building had been
occupied uh in breach of that condition
in other words by somebody who wasn't an
agricultural worker for at least 10
years that was granted
uh we also we subsequently received
quite a belt and braces approach an
application to delete that condition
entirely
um which was also granted since it was
clearly no longer uh valid
um following that we've had uh three
applications two prior approvals and a
further lawful development certificate
uh confirming that uh upwards and
railwoods extensions would be permitted
automatically by by planning law all of
those were approved and we'll get into
those a little bit later on
um
relevant here is uh I'm very grateful to
the applicant's agent there's cash more
for providing these figures
um saves me a lot of work
um on the top you see the existing floor
areas total of 110 square meters in the
middle the volume
410.7 meters cubed
this is what's proposed uh you'll note
it's now a two-story uh four bed
dwelling
with a total floor area of 194 square
meters
um again we'll get into that on the next
slide I thought this was worth
highlighting though
um the heights of the the height of the
building in comparison firstly to the
fallback position again next slide for
that
um is is the blue dotted line there the
uh on the adjoining site which was
granted permission for two new dwellings
fairly recently
um you'll note that it's about 440
millimeters shorter than the ridge
height of of the adjoining dwelling
there the road does slope down although
the landing General does slope down and
so the adjoining barns to the uh north
um roughly are about about the length of
a scale rule shorter 345 mil
then the listed Farmhouse opposite it's
shorter than that by about 700
millimeters
um again here over on the bottom right
you can see uh there's a comparison with
the fullback position which is this
um so the uh I think the relevant part
for everyone's purposes here is
this
so as you can see what is proposed is
significantly larger than the existing
so we saw earlier it had a volume of
about 400 uh meters cubed roughly uh
we're now going up to 760 meters Cube
now normally this would be significantly
larger than the existing dwelling but
with those prior approvals and lawful
development statistics that I've
mentioned they've demonstrated that they
can build a dwelling perfectly lawfully
that has a volume of 799 square meters
we've seen earlier that it's gonna be
bigger that would be bigger
um bulkier and so forth what is proposed
has a
um
as the size of 716 meters cubed it is
therefore smaller than the fallback
position the fallback position is what
we're comparing the proposal against
basically
so this is a sort of panoramic view of
the streets scene in the middle is the
uh is the only way
um
to the left of the two new dwellings you
see there there's a there's there is an
existing driveway
um
you'll see that it's going to be
expanded slightly here in the bottom
left to create a turning area in a
parking area as well
um and then the bar the list the barns
are down here to the right of frame this
these are the barns from the rear of the
site
um you can just see the Bungalow over
here on the right
and this is the list of Farmhouse uh
lots of nice uh Dormers there which is a
feature of of this scheme as well and uh
finally this is the new dwelling to the
right and the Bungalow there the numbers
uh uh the parish meeting has objected
which is why we're here at committee uh
my recommendation however is to Grant
Planning Commission
Paul thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is and Dawn Fisher secretary and
Treasurer at Carlton birming compression
Council we also have things to Robert
and share
your piece of I thought you registered
it under the same uh item are you
planning to speak independently and I'm
speaking
um
marvelous that's absolutely fine with me
thank you
yes that was no fun all right thank you
I'm sorry about that
um okay so you have three notes I'll
give you three second warning and if you
can say something questions afterwards
otherwise you're ready uh follow me
the views of birminghamton Parish
meeting to be clear we do not object in
principle to the demolition of sea to
Bungalow and the replacement with a
house we take the view that of all
bedroom house of this volume is too
large and domineering for the plot which
is outlined in red on that slide
spirit and will not be visually
integrated with the surrounding build
environment that exists within its
vicinity a strap The District Council
planning policy consideration State
namely the recent development by the
same applicants for two two-bed local
market dwellings for local needs being
the two neighboring houses Heartland and
Buccaneer outlined in blue
according to Stratford District
council's core strategy guidance 6-12
Countryside Villages policy as-10 all
proposals will be thoroughly assessed
including the need to minimize impact on
the character of the local landscape and
to minimize impact on the occupiers and
users of existing properties in the area
see the Bungalow breaks both of those
principles with its sheer volume on a
minimum sized plot and a narrow road
the area outlined in white is the
parking and turning area allowed for the
two local market dwellings when the
applicant applied for these two houses
the president was set as to what is
acceptable for space around a dwelling
especially given the fact that cedar
bongoose footprint is proposed to be
moved forward towards the road thus
reducing the area for being turning and
marketing the applicant owns the land
behind the south of sea of I believe it
would make more sense to retain the
footprint and provide more land to the
Garden space if that is required this
would be the safest option student
Bungalow has nowhere near the same
amount of available space for parking or
turning as any of the neighboring
properties the importance of this is
further demonstrated with slide two
please
this slide shows the edge of the
carriageway and the point where Vehicles
access Main Street from see the Bumble
the road Narrows significantly thereby
creating a visual impairment when
joining the carriageway this will be
further exacerbated when reversing onto
the carriageway common sense tells us it
is imperative that Vehicles can access
Main Street in a forward direction for
safety reasons at this narrow point in
the village we believe the seed Bungalow
plot needs more space to turn around
within the property boundary on-road
parking is definitely not to be
encouraged on this particular section as
the width of Main Street there's only
5.6 meters at this point narrowing to
3.3 meters it would worryingly prevent
the passage of emergency vehicles 30
seconds it is to be noted that
Warwickshire County Council highways
went to Great Lakes to ensure the
visibility spray foresee The Bungalow or
the met with safety guidelines when
assessing the partner and Buccaneer plot
now is a time to ensure the same safety
standards are maintained thank you
perfect thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions about
Crash Council sentences
no in that case thank you very much
because I'm contribution and of course
your patience as well thank you thank
you
I will call our last speaker at the
evening who is James Ashmore good
evening thank you for your patience to
do
thank you good evening
we would like to thank the County
officer for his hard work on this
application the application is before
members because of the parity meeting
injection there have been no other
objections to the application in total
there have been three third-party
letters submitted all from Birmington
residents and all of which support the
application
the paretrating objection has been
considered by your officer in their
report but responding to the points that
the parish rail is firstly the proposed
filing would not be out of keeping with
the scale and size of nearby properties
its footprint is only slightly large
among the existing and is smaller than
the fallback which I shall mention in
more detail later
the overall Heights it's suitably in the
street scene as shown on submitted plans
the mvpx seeks to make the efficient use
of land and adequate immunity area
included Garden area is provided for
future occupants as set out in the
committee report
the parachuting comments refer to
preference for a single story property
however this doesn't align with local
comments received which indicate they
wish to see more family housing in
Village this proposed replacement dry
labels provide for that
which is unattractive and attracts
visually from the street scene
the development would positively
contribute to the freezing and your
officer considers that it would enhance
the setting of nearby listed buildings
with regard to highways matters
Warwickshire County Council highways
have considered the application and
raised no objections subject to a
condition
what the parish meeting response does
not appear to consider is the fallback
position the fullback position
established through prior approval and
Global development certificate confirm
that an upwards extension and civil
story rare extension could be carried
out to see The Bungalow and this is a
material consideration in the
determination of this application the
plans show the fallback and the planning
officer has detailed this earlier and
it's within the community report
the respect to volume floor space and
Footprints the proposed replacement
dwelling is smaller than the full map
proposal replacement dwelling is also
lower in height this is less impactful
on the local area and setting of nearby
list of buildings
the fallback would result in a taller
and bulkier house with greater impact on
the street scene less parking area and
would not offer the sustainability and
energy benefits or street team
improvements that would be realized
through the proposed replacement 30
cents what is the post in this
application is therefore far practical
the proposed development would result in
a positive addition to the housing stock
in Burlington and result in an
enhancement to the local area I hope
you're able to support your officer
recommendation to Grants and thank you
for listening
thank you very much indeed because do we
have any questions
hi Jay good to see you um
there was a concerned
um
about the size of the product itself and
and this actually fitting on is it
trying to squeeze something into them
next week and it's been moved forward
so in terms of the April Society
Paul can hear me and just zoom in
slightly on that ground floor plan but
what the left-hand ground floor plan
shows on there as you can see adopted
life which shows the existing seed of
bungalow
um
side of the main building right so the
proposed replacement to adding is
actually only marginally larger in
footprint terms than we existing and
it's actually smaller than before back
in terms of garden areas and the
National Technical space standards the
proposed house fits we did all of those
and in terms of garden actually both of
those respected it seems
so it actually gives a little bit more
outcome
yes so the proposed replacement dwelling
it is not as you can see it's slightly
further forward than that existing
dotted line which does create slightly
larger for a garden area
[Music]
foreign
cars Parts on that site then they're
maybe even reversing out onto the
highway
um however Warwickshire County Council
highways have been projected for the
application and reversing us onto the
highway is not uncommon in the village
of Burlington
behind this
no in that case thank you very much for
your time contribution any questions too
let's move to positive applications
about officers does anyone have anything
they would like verify
no let's move
Council Jennings
I think this was all about the fallback
position
um changes to Commitment development for
now add extra doors also most positive
loans and most certain levels of
circumstances
um this is actually going to be smaller
than the fullback
highways that have been with the
uh have no objections and they're happy
with plans
um I can't say anything material
planning region to go against the
officer's decision on this so I'm happy
to propose that we've provided thank you
Council James
oh was it cancer Canada please
yeah
to me that's fitting in the street scene
there was a time
um it fits in the
outside so I'm happy to go with those
recommendations thank you if anyone else
can say anything about a time otherwise
we're going to move cancel out yeah I do
probably agree I think we did do the
fallback and I just sort of like to know
that I do
appreciate your concerns that have come
about the access regarding the parking
but as they said they need to provide
these faces they are providing their
spaces and there's kind of a limit that
so as much as I appreciate it might be
useful
thank you very much um
so the proposal is to start in line with
offers a recommendation
is unanimous so committee therefore
results to Grants Backpage
in that case thank you all very much for
your science contributions and patients
this evening and we'll see you next week
thank you very much
thank you